foreign
welcome in front of the offices of South
Korea's president Yun tsukyol for
visiting prime minister fumio kashida of
Japan
the two leaders heralding a new era in a
complicated and often troubled
relationship
after a recent increase in provocative
missile testing by North Korea both
leaders have taken a similarly tough
stand against their common neighbor
prime minister kishida and I shared the
understanding that North Korea's nuclear
and missile development poses a
significant threat to peace and
stability not only to the Korean
Peninsula and Japan but also to the
whole world to respond to this
trilateral cooperation between South
Korea the United States and Japan is
essential
on his arrival in South Korea kashida
paid his respects at the National
Cemetery that commemorates soldiers
killed in the Korean War but also
Independence Fighters during Decades of
Japanese colonial rule it's partly
because of that Legacy and South Korea's
suffering during World War II that led
to relations souring in recent years and
that Yoon has been trying to repair
there is also a sense of kind of fatigue
over these repeated requests by South
Korea for greater apologies on the side
of Japan overall there's been more a
desire on the part of the Japanese
public and the Japanese government to
move on from this difficult relationship
improving relations led to Yoon visiting
kashida in Tokyo in mid-march
in accordance with the direction
president Yun and I showed at the March
meeting Japan's South Korea dialogue and
cooperation have dynamically progressed
in less than two months
buttunes push to restore relations with
a traditional adversary have proved
unpopular at home contributing to a
nearly 60 disapproval rating and to
president that's in sharp contrast to
the approval he's received from the
administration of U.S President Joe
Biden who welcomed him on a state visit
last month
looking on approvingly at these warming
relations is the United States as its
two most powerful allies in East Asia
Washington seized Japan and South Korea
as a counter not only to North Korean
threats but also to the expanding
influence of China and the leaders of
all three are expected to hold a
trilateral on the sidelines of the
upcoming G7 Summit in Hiroshima Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Seoul